let's get some of the reaction from the
mainstream media here is Al Sharpton who
is a host on uh he is a well he's a race
huckster and also a host on the
televised mental institution known as
MSNBC but here he is in his limo uh
because I guess this was all happening
on the Fly well I think uh
this is 10 amount this
is what they have now is that it is
unconstitutional to even consider rates
this is a tremendous setback that must
be resisted by every corner including
the Department of Justice and including
States
if it wasn't for considering race this
guy this guy would have no gig but it's
just so funny because the things that
Martin Luther King Jr were fighting
against the idea that universities would
have quotas to keep black people out
things of that nature are now the exact
things that in 2023 when we've basically
put racism to bed Douglas I think it's
you that always say but they're you know
they're keeping it on life support
um here he is making the racist argument
as the anti-racist Peter again it's just
yeah here we go and of course did you
notice how he was not only doing it in
the back of the limousine but he was
also doing it while wearing a five
thousand dollar suit that's the kind of
Oppression it was like a 75 jacket by
the way right I mean yeah I could get
into that kind of impression you know
yeah I could do that don't you also love
that I mean this is a man let's remember
I don't think we need to linger over
over the so-called Reverend Al Sharpton
this is so Shameless that whenever a
young black man in America dies he
literally pushes is his way to the front
of the funeral Cortez and will be
standing in front of the family at the
coffin of a person he never knew trying
desperately to get his bit of the action
I mean
this is a man who's Shameless for a
living and of course he's Furious uh
that uh that uh in one way that people
are calling out the kind of race
huckstering that he's done but as you
say Dave if if if if if this kind of
so-called anti-racist racism didn't
exist whether the Reverend Al Sharpton
wouldn't have any reason to get into his
limousine in the morning there's a
phrase that I love that most people
credit uh Bill Maher for but believe it
or not it was George W bush the soft
bigotry of low expectations uh and watch
this clip this is also from MSNBC this
is contributor Eddie gowd on what will
now happen at the universities but it we
will return to uh Elite institutions
more more specifically uh being the
space for a particular population for
predominantly white and Asian students
we will begin to see a kind of
segregated uh uh higher education
landscape and the irony of Courts as I
try to I've anticipated this decision
but to hear it I'm kind of still I'm
trying to manage my emotions but you
know
this was just one remedy affirmative
action the only remedy to the legacy of
discrimination and admissions in
American higher education he's actually
saying the most depressing thing you
could say to a young black person or
brown person which is yeah it doesn't
matter it doesn't matter how hard you
work you're never going to make it which
is so contrary to the millions and
millions of black people who have
succeeded and become Millionaires and
own their own businesses and everything
else it's it's like it's most
soul-crushing way of viewing the world I
think exactly exactly and it's also
factually incorrect if you look at the
data for University admissions
white men are almost invisible on
University campuses that they are no
longer really going to University
they've opted out of Academia so I don't
know where he's getting this idea from
that University is going to be overrun
by terrible awful oppressive wine people
most most white men are not going to
college so he's got nothing to worry
about